Transcriptor: Rocio Pérez Maier
Revisor: Daniela Pardo
¡Hola!
¿Os acordáis del año 92?
El año 92, para España,
fue un año muy importante.
Fue el año del AVE,
fue el año de la expo de Sevilla,
fue el año de los Juegos
Olímpicos de Barcelona.
Yo recuerdo nítidamente
dónde estaba en el 92.
En el 92 estaba aquí
en la Politécnica, aquí al lado,
y acababa de empezar primero de carerra.
Ahora todos estaréis calculando mi edad.
(Risas)
Y en el 92, cayó en mi manos
un artículo científico
que hablaba de dos cosas
aparentemente disconexas.
El artículo hablaba de
el cerebro y la informática.
Cosas que aparentemente
están totalmente disconexas.
El artículo prometía
un concepto inquietante
que era: redes neuronales
que aprenden de la experiencia.
Lo cual se postulaba
como uno de los Santos Griales
de la informática,
como una de las promesas.
Y vamos a ver por qué.
En la informática,
si tú quieres resolver un problema,
típicamente tienes que tener en cuenta
todos los casos posibles
y programar para que tu programa
responda de una manera o de otra.
Pero hay problemas
que nos pueden parecer muy sencillos
y resulta muy difícil
codificarlos de esta manera.
Esto que os he contado,
a los informáticos, a los ingenieros
nos gusta llamarlo algoritmo.
Lo habréis oído alguna vez: algoritmo.
Pues bien, hay muchos problemas
que nos parecen muy sencillos,
para los cuales es muy difícil
hacer un algoritmo.
Y vamos a ver un ejemplo.
Un ejemplo tan sencillo
como diferenciar un perro de un gato.
¿Verdad que parece fácil?
Entonces vamos a hacer un juego
y vamos a intentar hacer un algoritmo
viendo las fotos del perro y del gato,
a ver si somos capaces
de diseñar un algoritmo.
Viendo la foto del perro podéis pensar:
“Bueno, los perros tienen orejas redondas,
con lo cual el algoritmo
si ve que tiene orejas redondas,
pues va a ser un perro.
Y los gatos tienen orejas puntiagudas,
ya tenemos el algoritmo, ¿no?"
Pues bueno, no tan rápido.
Porque enseguida va a aparecer un perro
con las orejas puntiagudas
y un gato con orejas redondas.
Y así va a pasar,
si nos fijamos en el hocico,
en la piel, en las garras, etc., ¿vale?
Por eso es tan sumamente difícil
hacer algoritmos para problemas
que aparentemente son tan sencillos,
como clasificar un perro de un gato.
Así que yo estaba en el año 92,
con toda la energía
de un alumno de primero de carrera.
Cayó en mis manos un artículo,
veía un problema complicadísimo,
que es clasificar una imagen
de un perro y un gato
y me puse a programar.
Yo recuerdo que me puse a programar
como un loco, por las noches,
aquella red neuronal
que se supone que
aprendía de la experiencia.
Aprendía viendo fotografías de perros
y gatos como hacemos las personas.
Son el Santo Grial de la informática,
una promesa hasta entonces incumplida.
Y bueno, me puse a programar
y aquello no funcionaba.
Estuve noches y noches,
hasta que al final un día,
llegaban los exámenes y dejé de programar.
Tenía que aprobar.
Y no solo yo, había muchos más
investigadores que en esa época
experimentaron con redes neuronales
y no resolvieron el problema
del aprendizaje con la experiencia.
De este modo, pasó el tiempo
y los ingenieros, los programadores,
nos dedicamos a resolver problemas
más accesibles con algoritmos.
Y habían algunos problemas intocables,
como la clasificación de imágenes,
que no tocábamos.
Sin embargo, mientras pasaba el tiempo,
estaban ocurriendo
dos revoluciones delante nuestro
que la mayoría no nos dimos cuenta.
La primera revolución que ocurrió
vino de donde uno menos se lo espera.
Vino de los videojuegos.
Los videojuegos.
¿Qué tendrán que ver
los videojuegos con el cerebro?
Pues resulta que los videojuegos,
en tres dimensiones,
utilizan una operación matemática
que recordareis de las matemáticas
de antes de la Universidad,
que es la multiplicación de matrices.
Muchos les tomaríais manía,
pues sirven para jugar.
Pues bien, la multiplicación de matrices
es una operación clave
para las redes neuronales.
Clave.
Y a medida que los videojuegos
aumentan en calidad,
aumentan en prestaciones.
A medida que ocurre eso,
aumenta la capacidad posible
de cómputo, cada vez más barata.
Esa fue la primera revolución.
La segunda revolución,
que ocurrió en el 2007,
ocurrió gracias a otra cosa
también aparentemente inconexa,
a los teléfonos móviles, al iPhone.
En el 2007 salió el primer iPhone.
¿Qué hacíamos con los iPhones?
Quizás más que llamar
por teléfono, hacer fotos.
No paramos de hacer fotos
que las ponemos en Internet.
No paramos de hacer fotos que ponemos
en Internet y que pueden ser etiquetadas.
Fotos que sirven, potencialmente,
para entrenar redes neuronales.
Y tanto es así, que en el 2012,
hubo una competición internacional
del problema que os he puesto
al principio de clasificar imágenes.
Más complicado que perros y gatos.
Hay que clasificar una imagen
en mil categorías.
¿Y sabeis quién ganó en el 2012?
No la gente que utilizó
algoritmos convencionales
de si la oreja es así, hago una cosa,
o si el hocico es así, hago otra, no.
Ganó un equipo que utilizó
redes neuronales
entrenadas con imágenes
sacadas de Internet,
utilizando tarjetas gráficas
de videojuegos.
Aquí podéis ver el primer equipo,
es el que tiene la barra más pequeña,
el error, cómo vaporizó los resultados
en clasificación de imágenes.
Este equipo,
fue el que dio el pistoletazo de salida
de la inteligencia artificial.
Aunque la inteligencia artificial
ya existía, hoy en día realmente,
estamos escuchando mucho
lo de la inteligencia artificial,
y en verdad viene motivado
por las redes neuronales.
Gracias a la capacidad de cálculo,
motivada por los videosjuegos,
y a las grandes cantidades
de imágenes sacadas de Internet.
Desde entonces,
las redes neuronales
han superado ya a la capacidad humana
en deducción de imagenes,
sirven al colectivo de medicina
para ayudar al diagnóstico,
incluso para el diseño de enfermedades,
y hay un campo que
también es muy interesante,
y es es de la cognición autónoma.
La cognición autónoma
promete un Santo Grial también,
que es mejorar la seguridad
en las carreteras, entre otras cosas.
Cada año mueren
más de un millón de personas
en las carreteras, todos los años.
Tanto es así, que al ser un problema
no resuelto, muchas empresas
crean desafíos y competiciones,
como la que en su día ocurrió en el 2012,
para ver si la comunidad científica ayuda.
Yo me sentía, de alguna manera,
en deuda desde el año 92
con las redes neuronales y vi que Alibaba,
una de las empresas punteras de China,
y como sabéis China es un país puntero
en inteligencia artificial,
había convocado una competición
para la conducción autónoma.
Una competición de inteligencia artificial
aplicada a la conducción autónoma.
Entonces lo intenté,
cogí toda la energía de mis 17 años
e intenté apuntarme a la competición,
pero fijaos lo que pasó.
Me voy al formulario para apuntarme
y ellos decían que estaba abierta
a todo el mundo,
pero me pedían un teléfono chino.
Claro, yo no tengo un teléfono chino
y ahora menos con el coronavirus, ¿no?
(Risas)
Y bueno les escribí: "Oye,
por favor, dejadme apuntarme,
estoy en España, me interesa
mucho la competición".
Y no me respondieron, claro.
(Risas)
Ya estaba a punto de escribir en Twitter:
“Maldita sea, esto
no puede ser", de quejarme
Sabía que si me quejaba
ya nunca más podría entrar en China.
No se puede, entonces claro,
pero os lo prometo,
antes de darle al botón,
vuelvo a chequear el formulario
y: ¡Mirad! ¡Admitido España!
(Risas)
¡Conseguí meter a España con China!
(Aplausos)
Bueno eso era lo fácil,
ahora viene lo difícil, que es competir.
(Risas)
La competición era muy complicada,
consistía en detectar obstáculos
de conducción real en China,
que eso es una locura también,
mucha gente no tiene carnet,
la gente no lo sabe.
Y bueno, ¿qué utilicé?
¿Algoritmos convencionales? No.
Utilicé redes neuronales,
utilizando datos de Internet
con tarjetas gráficas
y junto con mi compañero Pavel,
que lo conocí haciendo competiciones,
nos quedamos los primeros
a nivel mundial en China.
Y no solamente nos dieron un premio,
nos dieron 2 premios en esta competición
por la mejor solución,
que es un tema objetivo,
y la solución más ingeniosa
de toda la competición.
(Aplausos)
Y bueno, podemos pensar que ya está, ¿no?
Que ya hemos conseguido
el Santo Grial de las redes neuronales
que aprenden de la experiencia.
Pero bueno, ahora que ya tenemos
ese Santo Grial, esa promesa cumplida,
yo miro adelante y quiero ver
que ahora tenemos que exigirnos
sistemas de inteligencia
artificial más precisos,
artificial más éticos,
que no tengan sesgos, por ejemplo.
Sistemas de inteligencia artificial
que en definitiva sean más humanos.
Miro atrás, miro al año 92
y quiero que veáis
el nombre del investigador
que escribió el artículo.
Geoffrey Hinton.
Ahi tenéis su foto, en el 92.
Miro atrás, miro al 2012,
mirad los nombres de los investigadores.
Geoffrey Hinton, el mismo.
Veinte años esperó
este investigador, Geoffrey Hinton,
para lograr su sueño de redes neuronales
que aprenden de la experiencia.
Y quiero terminar,
recordándome a mí en el año 92,
con la frustración de no haber podido
entrenar la red neuronal.
Casi 30 años después,
me veo aquí
en el TEDx, habiendo logrado
después de tanto tiempo,
entrenar una red neuronal,
inspirado por investigadores
como Geoffrey Hinton y muchísimos más
y quiero pedir un aplauso para
todos los investigadores que nos inspiran.
(Aplausos)